6 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy let's revisit that
issue of nobody pays attention to the
speed limit in the airport connector
tunnels
a viewer who wishes to remain anonymous
right if I go the speed limit in the
tunnels I get honked at ran up on it
have lights flashed at me people are so
aggressive nobody goes 35. I feel like I
have to speed like everyone else for my
own safety
well Anonymous everyone here knows
exactly what you're talking about read
airport spokesman Joe Rachel told us
that before the speed limit was lowered
in 2019 there were 60 crashes in the
tunnels in the first six months of that
year in the first six months of last
year there were 19 crashes
so a reasonable conclusion is that even
if it seems like no one's following the
speed limit it must be having some kind
of positive impact Anonymous thanks for
writing stay safe wherever you go buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone if you'd like to join the driving
you crazy conversation it's traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com